so let's say i have some multivariable
function
like f of x y so it'll have a two
variable input is equal to i don't know
x squared times y
plus sine of y so it'll output just a
single number it's a scalar valued
function the question is how do we take
the derivative of an expression like
this
and there's a certain method called a
partial derivative which is very similar
to ordinary derivatives and i kind of
want to show how they're secretly the
same thing so to do that let me just
remind ourselves of how how we interpret
the notation for ordinary derivatives so
if you have something like f of x is
equal to x squared
and let's say you want to take its
derivative and i'll use the leibniz
notation here df dx
and let's evaluate it at 2 let's say i
really like this notation because it's
suggestive of what's going on if we
sketch out a graph
so you know this
axis represents our output
this over here represents our input and
x squared has a certain parabolic shape
to it something like that
then we go to the input x equals 1 2
this little dx here i like to interpret
as just a little nudge in the x
direction and it's kind of the size of
that nudge
and then df
df
is the resulting change in the output
after you make that initial little nudge
so
it's this resulting change and when
you're thinking in terms of graphs this
is slope you kind of have this rise over
run
for your ratio between the tiny change
of the output that's caused by a tiny
change in the input and of course this
is dependent on where you start over
here we have x equals two
but you could also think about this
without graphs if you really wanted to
you might just think about
you know your input space is just a
number line and your output space
also is just a number line
the output of f over here and really
you're just thinking of somehow mapping
numbers from here onto the second line
and in that case your initial nudge your
initial little dx
would be some nudge on that number line
and you're wondering how that influences
the the function itself so maybe that
causes a nudge that's you know four
times as big and that would mean your
derivative is
four at that point
so the reason that i'm talking about
this is because over in the
multivariable world we can pretty much
do the same thing
you know you could write
df
dx
and interpret that as saying hey how
does a tiny change in the input in the x
direction influence the output but this
time the way that you might visualize it
you'd be thinking of your input space
here i'll draw it down here as the x y
plane so this time this is not going to
be graphing the function this is every
point on the plane is an input
and let's say you were evaluating this
at a point like 1 2.
okay
in that case so you go over to the input
that's one
and then two
and then you'd say okay so this tiny
nudge in the input this tiny change dx
how does that influence the output and
in this case the output i mean it's
still just a number so maybe we go off
to the side here
and we draw
just like a number line as our output
and somehow we're thinking about the
function as mapping points on the plane
to the number line so you'd say okay
that's your that's your dx how much does
it change the output
and you know maybe this time it changes
it negatively it depends on your
function
and that would be your df
and you can also do this with the y
variable right there's no reason that
you can't say
df
dy
and evaluated that same point 1 2
and interpret totally the same way
except this time your d y
would be a change in the y direction
so maybe i should really emphasize here
that that dx
that that dx is a change in the x
direction here and that d y is a change
in the y direction and maybe when you
change your f according to y it does
something different right maybe you know
the output increases and it increases by
a lot it's more sensitive to y again it
depends on the function
um and i'll show you how you can compute
something like this in in just a moment
here but first there's kind of an
annoying thing associated with partial
derivatives where we don't write them
with d's in dxdf
people came up with this new notation
mostly just to emphasize to the reader
of your equation that it's a
multi-variable function involved and
what you do
is you say uh you write a d but it's got
kind of a curl at the top it's this new
symbol and people will often read it as
partial so you might read like partial
left partial y
if you're wondering by the way why we
call these partial derivatives it's sort
of like this doesn't tell the full story
of how f changes because it only cares
about the x direction neither does this
this only cares about the y direction so
each one is only um
a small part of the story
so let's actually evaluate something
like this
i'm going to go ahead and clear the
board over here i think the
one dimensional analogy
is something we probably have already
so
a little remnants
so if you're actually evaluating
something like this here i'll write it
again up here partial derivative of f
with respect to x
and we're doing it at one two it only
cares about movement in the x direction
so it's treating y as a constant it
doesn't even care about the fact that y
changes as far as it's concerned y is
always equal to 2. so we can just plug
that in ahead of time
so i'm going to say partial partial x
this is another way you might write it
put the expression in here and i'll say
x squared but instead of writing y i'm
just going to plug in that constant
ahead of time
because when you're only moving in the x
direction this is kind of how
how the multivariable function sees the
world and i'll just keep a little note
that we're evaluating this whole thing
at x equals one
and here this is actually just an
ordinary derivative right this this is
an expression that's an x you're asking
how it changes as you shift around x and
you know how to do this this is just
taking the root of taking the derivative
the derivative of
x squared times 2 is going to be 4x
because x squared goes to 2x and then
the derivative of a constant sine of 2
is just a constant is 0.
and of course we're evaluating this at x
equals 1. so your overall answer is
going to be 4.
and just for practice let's also do that
with the derivative with respect to y so
we look over here i'm going to write the
same thing you're taking the partial
derivative of f with respect to y
we're evaluating it at the same point 1
2 this time it doesn't care about
movement in the x direction
so as far as it's concerned that x just
stays constant at 1 so we'd write 1
squared times y
plus sine of y
sine of y
and you're saying oh i'm keeping track
of this at y equals 2
so that's kind of you're evaluating at y
equals 2. when you take the derivative
this is just 1 times y so the derivative
is 1.
this over here the derivative is cosine
cosine of y
again we're evaluating this whole thing
at y equals 2.
so your overall answer it would be you
know 1 plus
cosine of 2. i'm not sure i'm not sure
what the value of cosine of 2 is off the
top of my head but that would be your
answer
and
this is this is a partial derivative at
a point
but a lot of times you're not asked to
just compute it at a point what you want
is a general formula that tells you hey
plug in any point x y and it should spit
out the answer
so let me just kind of go over how you
would do that it's actually very similar
but this time instead of plugging in the
constant ahead of time we just have to
pretend that it's a constant
so let me um let me make a little bit of
space for ourselves here
really
we don't need any of this anymore
i'm going to leave the partial partial f
partial partial y
we want this as a more general function
of x and y
well we kind of do the same thing
we're going to say that this is you know
derivative with respect to x and i'm
using partials just to kind of emphasize
that it's
a partial derivative but now we'd write
x squared and then kind of emphasize
that it's a constant value of y
plus the sine
and again
i'll say y and here
i'm writing the variable y but we have
to pretend like it's a constant now
you're pretending that you plug in 2 or
something like that and you still just
take the derivative so in this case the
derivative of x squared times a constant
is just 2x times that constant 2x times
that constant and over here the
derivative of a constant is always 0. so
that's just always going to be 0.
so this is your partial derivative as a
more general formula if you plugged in 1
2 to this you'd get what we had before
and similarly if you're doing this with
f of
partial f partial y
we write down all of the same things now
you're taking it with respect to y
and i'm just going to copy this formula
here actually
but this time we're considering all of
the x's to be constants so in this case
when you take the derivative with
respect to y of some kind of constant
you know constant squared is a constant
times y
it's just going to equal that constant
so this is going to be x squared
and over here you're taking the
derivative of sine of y there's no x's
in there so that remains
the sine of y
if you can clear and now this is a more
general formula if you plugged in one
two you would get one so oh sorry that's
cosine of y
because we're taking a derivative
so if you plugged in one two you know
you would get one plus the cosine of one
which is what we had before so this this
is really what you'll see for how to
compute a partial derivative you pretend
that one of the variables is constant
and you take an ordinary derivative and
in the back of your mind you're thinking
this is because you're just moving in
one direction
for the input and you're seeing how that
influences things and then you know you
might move in one direction for another
input and see how that influences things
in the next video i'll show you what
this means in terms of graphs and slopes
but it's important to understand that
graphs and slopes are not the only way
to understand derivatives because as
soon as you start thinking about
vector-valued functions or functions
with inputs of higher dimensions than
just two you can no longer think in
terms of graphs but this idea of nudging
the input in some direction seeing how
that influences the output and then
taking the ratio you know the ratio of
that output nudge to the input nudge
that's a more general way of viewing
things and that's going to be very
helpful moving forward in multivariable
case